ladies and gentlemen director colin
trevorov
uh emily carmichael screenwriter did i
say it wrong
[Applause]
screenwriter
emily carmichael
bryce dallas howard
dewanda
dwanda wise
and and somebody named and someone named
jeff goldblum
i want to i want to start with a uh
apology to colin trevorrow
how long have we known each other
honest to god i'm mortified right now
but i say trivoro right trevor it's like
tomorrow
i i have no words i just want to get
nervous still to this day like i like in
my head will be like tomorrow tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow
trevor like tomorrow yeah yeah so don't
worry it's yeah thank you bryce yeah i
want to start with the fact that we are
live in 71 imax theaters around north
america right now everywhere from
montreal to california there's a ton of
people watching you guys
how is it cool to be
like in front of all these people at
once well it's cool to be in new york
guys i'm from new york this is my
childhood movie theater i came to this
movie theater so many times i protested
in front of this movie theater when they
wouldn't let us in to see a matinee
because we were high school students and
we were supposed to be in school
very meaningful to be here
so i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and i
think everyone in this audience if
you're coming to you know jurassic world
dominion opening night you're a fan and
i'm curious for for the people out there
for each of you what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
actual making of the movie
i still get the question about what it's
like to work with a tennis ball and i'm
proud to report that there was very
little tennis ball acting
so i just think the level of uh
practical effects in this film was
absolutely astonishing as a blockbuster
newbie it's very helpful
uh so i'm sure i'll be obnoxious my next
time around like oh it's not here
where are
[Laughter]
amateur hour yeah so i think uh you know
i cannot emphasize that enough because
it's incredible and it takes a lot of
craftsmanship and a whole lot of people
to make that happen
anyone else
let's see um
you know i'm thinking of what you might
really be interested in you've seen
again because these days you know you
see all manner of you know uh what it
was like and you meet john nolan the
creature shop uh creator of all the
things but we we did we've talked about
this before um colin our wonderful
director had us all in a hotel probably
you know because of covert of course but
we we rehearsed he was very
collaborative as we've talked about but
the way we all work together maybe maybe
somebody here or watching would be
interested in how we kind of opened
things up from the beautiful script that
you guys wrote and actually used our
weekends to go through the material that
was going to be shot the next week
and really went you know you'd be we
didn't take any photo pictures or videos
of what we did but those were rehearsals
i did i took a lot i did i did too i did
too like a creep i have so many photos
of you jeff really it's fine
just wait till next week
i i did too i have like secret videos
okay secret videos exist
uh
i just the idea of you know something
that reshaped people's lives uh for 30
years that these are
these are powerful words and these
characters these icons that uh laura sam
and jeff played uh they mean so much to
us they were powerful uh and they were
heroes and uh inspired so many kids to
become scientists and paleontologists
and
uh to me as as we thought about
everything we were going to do as we
tried to figure out how we were going to
make sure these these characters changed
uh and were honored the way our our
bryce and chris were going to relate to
them what they would know about them our
new characters edwanda wise mama duache
everybody coming together to be able to
to show the same level of reverence and
respect and then just shake it up and
put them on a real adventure and send
them into actual danger
we're here in an imax theater i love
imax what are you most excited colin for
audiences to see in imax tonight
uh well we have some pretty massive
dinosaurs in this movie but we we also
have a sequence uh racing through the
streets of malta uh that we shot uh over
a very long period of time with actual
motorbikes uh and an actual vehicle that
these two were driving uh and it's it's
it's a really exhilarating scene i've
seen in imax and so it's it's so
completely immersive also the sound in
this theater we have an animal that uh
pretty much just communicates with
echolocation and so you hear it in every
single speaker except the one that it's
coming from which is really disorienting
i'm so curious for the two of you
what would have happened if like jeff
had said no i don't want to do this
oh we wouldn't do it
i wouldn't i mean
what would have happened like a
contingency plan to like strong harm him
i mean what well if the original cast
had said you know i don't know if we
want to come back what would have
happened oh no in the beginning you know
that they were on board that i mean
because we knew bd wong was obviously in
the first drastic world which was
incredibly validating since he was in
jurassic park
and then in fallen kingdom jeff joined
which was like
jeff goldblum is now involved and then
for dominion with with laura dern and
sam neil when did you know that laura
and sam specifically were were on board
i feel like everyone said yes in
principle right away and they were
excited right away but there was then
that that conversation uh about well
where have you been and what have how do
you see this new world that's been
created what's your perspective and i
think that actors are authorities on
their characters i think they know more
about who they are than i can ever know
because they think about their character
all day every day uh and you know my
brain has to be in a lot of different
places so if i have a question about
what ian malcolm would think i'll ask
jeff goldblum
the um
um well first of all the premise of the
question in what crazy alternate
universe would i have ever said no
that doesn't exist i don't care how many
multi-verses there are there's
none none of them have me saying no but
had i for some reason
been unable to do it i'm sure it would
have been like that tv series bewitched
without any explanation they would have
replaced me in this uh movie with
possibly john turturro
possibly kevin kline i don't know i'm
sure the list is um long and uh uh
fruitful and we might all have been
better dr ian malcolm there is one and
it's you sir i'll get out of there
[Laughter]
uh bryce i'm curious in the last few
years you've been doing some directing
you've directed the mandalorian
and
i believe book of boba fett
and i'm curious how that's changed you
as an actor like when you step foot on a
set like this
is what's going through your brain in
terms of you know what i mean yeah no
absolutely i think that i mean what's so
wonderful
about getting to be an actor who's
interested in directing or studying
directing is that you get to see a lot
of other directors work
and that's something that my dad he
started off as an actor doing andy
griffith show and happy days and
films like the shootest and and american
graffiti and then when he started
directing he stopped acting and he said
that's the thing that he misses the most
getting to see how different directors
solve problems because that's really
what directors are they're they're
they're constant problem they're
visionaries and then they're problem
solvers
and so just in the last i've been i've
been getting to work um on on
mandalorian since 2018 and and having
john favreau as my mentor and dave
filoni as my star wars mentor has been
and i know they're the incredible
incredible
uh artists and uh and visionaries and so
learning from them and then going to
make a movie like dominion
i mean i was i was a little annoying
because i was like i just want to follow
you around and i just wanted to see
everything i want to see the visual
effects i want to see how you do it
because it's very rare to gain access
like that to a process like this
and
uh i one of the reasons why i wanted to
i actually shadowed my dad when he when
he directed a movie called solo and i
remember us talking about it when that
all happened
um it it was an opportunity for me now
that i was a professional actor
to watch my dad be a director and to
understand what he was doing so the more
you learn the more you understand but
the more you're enlightened by each
filmmaker that you get to encounter and
so that's why i hope i hope to i hope to
get to continue to direct but i also
hope to get to continue to act because
it's the best way to learn and one thing
that i should just say is um
i a moment that i really remember i was
doing a movie called pete's dragon and
uh wonderful filmmaker dave lowry
directed that and uh he's he's young
he's the same age as as me and um i mean
i'm 41 but like he when we were making
it he was in his mid 30s and um and
robert redford was on set and robert
redford is one of the most experienced
uh multifaceted uh talented people in in
the history of our industry and he was
asking
dave so many questions
and he was he was so curious about the
technology and i was like if robert
redford
is is using acting as an opportunity to
learn more about filmmaking then that's
how every director should be operating
as far as i'm concerned jumping into
some fan questions that we have here
alexander diaz is asking after 30 years
of this franchise existing would you
change anything
i don't ask me i i can't watch any of
the movies change everything all the
time there's
if any of you have ever directed
anything it's very very hard to to be
truly satisfied with your own work but
you're constantly trying to do something
that feels absolutely the most honorable
to the source material and yet truly new
and different and fresh and bold all at
the same time
so i'd throw that to the rest of you
oh i just i'm just i can't wait to see
more um i think it would be cool to see
jurassic movies in like different parts
of the world to have like the swamp
crawl jurassic movie or like the
spelunking disaster jurassic movie or
maybe like the corporate boardroom no
that would be a bad one forget i said
that one um but like cool other
locations i think that would be really
thrilling
because we have so many fan questions if
you don't mind let's move on to the next
one so corey wants to know if jurassic
perk really existed would you go nobody
here nobody on this panel not one person
on this panel i would go i would go
emily and we have a taker she doesn't
learn
somebody has to not learn in order for
the story to go on
jeff would you go
yes
yes
yes so that i could uh
start some leverage on the decision
makers and possibly
change their minds for the better
thank you
uh trish wants to know what was your
favorite moment in a jurassic movie that
you did not star in
kitchen scene
in the first jurassic park
you know
the green jello leading into the kitchen
that whole sequence unreal
well i didn't start in any moment so
this is an easy question for me but the
moment when bryce and dwanda's character
meet in our movie remains one of my
favorite sequences
yeah we meet in a bathroom spoiler in a
bathroom the ladies room in a lady's
room
uh well off the top of my head in um
wasn't it the la uh i was in it but i
mean was it
in fallen kingdom in fallen kingdom
or was it in the world the first world
where the two brothers where the brother
has been get getting get away from me
your little little punk and then at some
point during the crisis he's like
you can count on me and the brothers
kind of unite we have two kids two
brothers and i thought that was
sweet you know jurassic world that was
that's jurassic world yes yes i love
that yeah
uh brian has a question for everyone um
if you could pick one dinosaur or if you
could pick any dinosaur to have as a pet
uh which dinosaur would you choose and
why
i mean i'd be stupid i'd go velociraptor
i'm sorry
you can't stop me you're consistent yeah
i just you're like bring that part back
she doesn't learn with the philosopher
she's so
beautiful it's true
well uh we're asking this believe it or
not uh all you know
what dinosaur what's up what dinosaur i
know we're asked this often uh i've
given a different answer every time and
now off the top of my head thinking
clearly i think it would be a compy i
think if i put that copy on a leash and
walk down the street with it it would be
pretty protective
i said copies earlier today when someone
asked that question and then i quickly
realized that the other day i saw two
rats within five minutes of each other
and copies is a lie
because copies are the rats of the
franchise in my opinion
[Laughter]
sparrow wants to know what was the most
challenging part about playing this role
which is clearly for the actors
which is clearly why for the actors over
the actors
i was just working on not pulling a
hamstring to be really you know it's
it's one thing to train for a role and
another thing to do uh something a
sequence repeatedly over and over and
over again with that level of adrenaline
and you know it's sprinting you know
it's not it's not cross-country it's
like sprinting every time um so yeah
just staying as well
uh and stretched as possible it's
probably the most challenging it's the
same for me yeah for sure you just
because the second there's an injury
game over and so it's your job to be
able to show up on set and deliver again
and again and again whatever it takes to
get there
um is is definitely a huge focus for us
so yeah taking taking some hits my
theory is that if it heals within a week
ish it's fine
i would say you know one answer off the
top of my head is you know in in many
different ways not to let the
opportunity down
you know uh you know and somehow come up
to an optimal
uh discharging of the obligation and so
that's kind of challenging in many
different ways but having heard you say
that oh yes there was a uh you remember
that day
and you see you'll see it in the movie
where i had to sprint like usain bolt
away from a dinosaur and as you know i
have not disclosed this yet to anyone
publicly and i won't tell them the whole
story but
there was running there was sprinting
involved and yes i was also concerned i
didn't want to i cause i have also done
pulled a hammy here and there on other
occasions i didn't want that to happen
you helped me on that night and then in
the editing you helped him some more you
helped me some more very gracefully uh
jeff jeff is very musical and and very
musical jazz kind of flows
where you can almost see him like
counting off as he's running time
keeping time in the run and so there was
a couple like well we don't need the
we don't need to keep time we don't need
the the that's right try that again jeff
but this time yeah that's right
um this is gonna be the last question
for you guys um this is from gabriel how
did you feel filming the last scene
knowing that this is the end of the
trilogy
no i just it was the most it was the
most emotional day of filming that i've
ever experienced
yeah it was the very last thing uh the
very last thing we did have had everyone
in it at the at the end of the film uh
everyone is packed into this tiny
helicopter and
when i looked in at all of you you were
to my right you're flying the helicopter
and then it looked like et's closet with
all of these faces
of all these people who i loved and who
i had made this film with uh and they
were all looking back at me and we were
all feeling the same thing it was it was
really the last shot that we did was
this whole group together and it's very
rare that you wrap all the actors on a
movie on the same night especially a
cast as large as this one uh and we've
been through a lot and so it was it was
it was very meaningful it was very
special
yeah for me it was it was meaningful too
but i got to tell you the truth the
truthful answer is
like oftentimes the last you know
because you've had last things here and
there after a big
you know investment of some kind i've
always kind of and probably as i
remember on this occasion too kind of
don't get too caught up with the goodbye
fellow actors hasn't this been fun
there's still something in that shot
whatever it was that
how do i make this good how do i not
make it bad you know how do i i don't
want to do it and then uh what could i
have done differently the last shot you
know so i'm kind of focused thinking you
know that's kind of what happens and
then when it when it ends you know
there's goodbye everybody and all that
but that takes a while sometimes for me
to process it's not all at once
that's the end we do you know a kind of
uh
you know expulsion of something or a
feeling of uh take my girdle off or you
know that kind of takes a little
processing i'm still kind of
processing it you know i think that's
really true it's it's i mean i remember
when we i was very emotional that night
for sure and i don't know if you
remember because we flew back together i
basically cried the entire
flight it was real sad bd wong was like
our leading lady is not okay
but um
even even the last few days because it's
something getting to do press is
something that we all get to look
forward to and realizing that this is
winding down you know it's it's it's an
opportunity to be all the more
intentional with our friendships moving
forward
and it is a new era
for so many of us
uh when it comes to this franchise you
know i mean it's been almost 30 years
and for us it's been almost eight years
and
um and for some of us it's a you know
a new beginning and so it's it is a very
meaningful very powerful experience i
think all of us will treasure and hold
on to forever
and it is incredibly bittersweet that
it's coming to a close because it has
been so wonderful so it's like the end
of summer camp you know yeah it is a pr
it's a profound privilege it really is a
profound privilege and like every moment
of life or
indoor it's passionate work to me i'm
always aspiring to
really appreciate it when it happens you
know
yeah but i gotta say i mean we've you
know we've been shooting this movie
we've been making this movie we've been
like screening this movie in like you
know studio spaces and like evaluating
the cut of this movie now that we're
here with a crowd in new york city who
came here to watch this movie this this
moment this is what it's all about
yeah thank you and also to everyone out
watching i just you know just to bring
you in on this this we've been we've
been on talking to people all over the
world for you know what's six weeks now
longer than that and we've been doing uh
so much uh to communicate to others how
we feel about this film about the work
that we did but this is kind of this is
the last time we're doing that you know
just right here right now uh and now
we we lay at your feet we we give it to
the audience and uh and it goes out into
the world and we hope you uh have as
much fun as we do so thank you
thank you
thank you
ladies and gentlemen i just want to let
everybody know that it's going to take
up a few minutes in this theater to pull
everything down and then the movie will
start but on that note ladies and
gentlemen the cast and filmmakers behind
jurassic world dominion
colin do you want to tell them something
oh yeah no very important very very
important very important um look i'm
from i'm from oakland and and in oakland
when we watch movies we get loud
okay so everybody uh watching an imax
everybody here all over
yell things at the screen you can laugh
you can cry do all of it loudly because
we're here together in a theater
watching a movie which hasn't happened
for a very long time so let's enjoy it
but
during my scenes absolute silence
i don't want to hear a pin job
all right no thank you
thank you thank you thank you so much
everyone thank you thank you
you